it's crazy because you've been doing
your thing for a long time but like to
finally catch like one of them ones that
crosses over in the united states yeah
how does that feel man
i mean it feels good you know um
love one sincere
really special song you know like people
from different ethnicities and languages
you know connect so heavy with the song
you know and it feels good to see that
happen no for sure people love the
record it's just a feel-good song give
me the backstory of the record how old
is the song too because sometimes songs
will become hits and we won't know they
might be two or three years old yeah i
mean i made love wanting to 2019
um
i think it came out around august on my
ep ck the first and it was track
um
then we released the video the music
video for the first remix in
february 2020
you know
that was like the first moment it had in
nigeria and africa it was already big in
africa
then like in 2021 it came back again you
know and like this time
it was like global you know literally
every country
on earth
so it's like it's like a legit like two
and a half year old song something like
that
and what was for you like did you notice
like a moment or something that happened
that kind of
gave it that that the last run it's been
on what was it yeah so it was um
so when i released it i had an acoustic
version
on my youtube
so um
in 2021 a dj from mauritius
um his name is dj yo so he took that
acoustic version and he put drums on it
and i don't know one thing that's the
one thing and it ended up on tick tock
and it just went crazy you know like
ridiculous it was a bootleg it was a
bootleg remake yeah yeah it wasn't even
official like we didn't even know about
the remix until you know it where it
went viral and we had to find the dj you
know where was he at but i'm just
wondering this he was like mauritius
who is dj what's his i didn't even know
his instagram i was i was looking for
his instagram here
and like you know um when we finally
found him
and my team reached out to like you know
reclaim the record literally the next
day
it became number one on shazam global
and it was number one for like
two three months straight his version
yeah
wow so yeah so basically that version
was like a
like a catalyst out there
that kind of led all the other versions
to going crazy too and is that the
version we hear on american radio
actually the version on american radio
is the original the og version the og
version but like
yeah mostly on on tick tock instagram
that's the remake it was it was that dju
version did we cut djo in absolutely
okay just make sure we got to take care
of that guy absolutely